la parole est à Monsieur Philippe Vigier
pour le groupe démocrate
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente madame la Première
ministre mesdames messieurs les
ministres
mes chers collègues
en démarrant ces propos au nom du groupe
démocrate dans le cas de ces nouvelles
motions de censure déposées par le
rassemblement national et les insoumis
je voudrais rappeler à chacun avec un
peu de solennité
que nous vivons dans une vraie
démocratie avec des pouvoirs et des
contre-pouvoirs prévus par la
Constitution en France la liberté
d'expression de manifester d'aller
devenir d'entreprendre est une réalité
de tous les instants
veillons collectivement mes chers
collègues sur ce précieux joyeux
et je dis cela avec force parce que
quand je vois les dérives auxquelles on
a assisté le week-end dernier dans les
Deux Sèvres
alors lorsque certains et même des
parlementaires semblent-ils est invité
la désobéissance civile c'est-à-dire au
non respect de la loi ce à quoi nous
avons assisté et totalement inacceptable
et abjecte
pensons une seconde mes chers collègues
aux citoyens du monde qui ne connaissent
de la démocratie que le mot
pensons aux opposants russes emprisonnés
aux familles raniennes courageuses
pensons aux Afghans livrés à
l'obscurantisme au nom de ce
contre-pouvoir chers collègues vous avez
les poser une motion de censure c'est
une surprise pour personne elle était
annoncée elle était prévisible vous ne
vouliez pas débattre mesdames messieurs
les censeurs chers collègues pour preuve
dès le début d'examen de cpfss dès le
début de l'examen de ces PLFSS vous avez
demandé quoi une motion de rejet
préalable ça veut dire quoi vous avez
voulu refuser que l'assemblée puisse
débattre de ces projets
c'est la vérité monsieur Guedj et nous
devons le dire à nos compatriotes qui
nous écoutent et qui nous regardent
alors quand vous parlez de brutalité du
gouvernement qui a déclenché l'article
49-3 vous avez été les premiers chers
collègues à déclencher les hostilités et
à brutaliser l'Assemblée nationale je
voudrais rappeler aussi que simplement
quelques minutes cher Pierre d'arriville
après le rejet de votre motion lors de
la discussion générale de ce PLFSS les
groupes de position ont d'entrée de jeu
annoncés qu'ils ne voteraient pas ce
budget le décor est ainsi planté
cette motion de censure collecte du RN
et insoumis vous donne en fait une
nouvelle tribune pour essayer de créer
le chaos permanent et renverser le
gouvernement quoi qu'il en coûte comme
vous avez essayé de le faire la semaine
dernière lors de la première motion sur
les budget unissant vos votes au mépris
de vos convictions et de vos électeurs
pour cette nouvelle motion de censure
puis elle est fait celle 2023 les choses
sont différentes les insoumis sont
devenus orphelins leurs alliés
socialistes écologistes
communiste non pas signé est-ce le signe
d'une fissure dans votre muraille en
carton ou alors le début du droit à la
paresse théorisée par les écologistes le
rassemblement national par la voie de sa
présidente Madame Le Pen a indiqué qu'il
ne voterait pas la motion des insoumis
s'est après midi
la partie de poker menteur de la semaine
dernière et donc terminé laissez-moi
terminer collègues peut-être peut-être
avez-vous été chaude car les insoumis
n'ont pas voté cette motion
mais je pense que s'il ne je pense que
si vous ces doutes sont levés c'est
parce que simplement vous êtes rendu
compte chers collègues lui ressemblant
national qu'avec la nuit Pesse vous êtes
en opposition sur l'essentiel
l'immigration la préférence nationale la
lutte contre les fraudes le soutien et
le respect que l'on doit aux forces de
l'ordre le fonctionnement de l'assurance
chômage ou l'avenir du mutualisme en
France l'un des vôtres d'ailleurs
monsieur Alliot je l'ai bien écouté hier
dans une grande émission avec l'arrêt
que si il s'opposait au gouvernement et
c'est son choix il ne souhaitait pas qui
est le chaos dans le pays et il ne
souhaitait pas qu'il y ait une stabilité
politique alors je voudrais dire enfin
aux collègues insoumis que dans une
république démocratique on respecte le
suffrage universel et que les présidents
de la République a été élu pour 5 ans le
peuple a tranché monsieur Coquerel le
peuple a tranché alors que même alors
que même
ne soyez pas plus intransigeant que tu
as été Trump pour reconnaître son
élection ne faites pas plus bol scénario
qu'un autre qui a du mal à reconnaître à
l'heure où je vous parle l'élection de
lilas à la présidence du Brésil chers
collègues du RN cesser de nous répéter
matin midi et soir que la nuit Pesse a
fait élire manuel Macron ce sont les
Français qui ont choisi ce sont les
Français qui ont choisi et vous êtes
bien trop avertis pour savoir que
beaucoup d'électeurs de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon du premier tour ont voté pour
Marine Le Pen au deuxième tour
l'émotion de censure
l'émotion de censure qui porte sur les
dépenses des cinq branches de sécurité
sociale créée en 1945 par le Conseil
National de la Résistance et bien qui à
l'époque je le dis chers collègues avis
Sud est passé les clivages politiques
puisqu’il est centriste des communistes
des socialistes des radicaux et bien sûr
des gaullistes avaient dépassé leurs
différences pour bâtir un modèle
universel de protection sociale regardez
et enviés par le monde entier chers
collègues
77 ans plus tard c'est tout le contraire
que les Français constatent aujourd'hui
ne concitoyens ils attendent du
gouvernement et du Parlement qu'on leur
apporte des réponses à leurs difficultés
quotidiennes et ils sont lassés
des
empoignades à répétition et du spectacle
qu'on leur propose ils ne le disent un
peu plus à chaque élection en
s'abstenant toujours plus massivement
dans une situation internationale
explosive avec la guerre en Ukraine avec
une pandémie qui compte parmi les 5 puis
meurtrières de tous les temps
devant un mur du coup de l'énergie pour
les particuliers pour les entreprises
pour les collectivités qui donnent le
vertige devant l'enjeu crucial de lutter
tous ensemble à l'échelle planétaire
contre le réchauffement climatique
l'exigence oui je dis bien l'exigence et
l'humilité devrait conduire chacun à
bâtir des compromis sans compromission
la première partie du PLFSS
la partie dépense pardon du pfss qui
nous rassemble cet après-midi c'est pas
moins de 550 milliards d'euros ah oui
sur ces sujets là bien sûr qu'il y a des
différences des différences d'approche
des différences liées à nos convictions
politiques parcours individuel ou
professionnel mais je suis certain qu'il
y a un chemin que nous pourrions bâtir
ensemble pour faire ses compromis sans
compromission mais avec le sens de
l'intérêt général la mission flash sur
les EHPAD madame la présidente de la
commission des affaires sociales n'en
était pas la belle illustration où toute
sensibilité politique confondues
le groupe de travail transpartisan sur
les sur les déserts médicaux Sébastien
Gimel dont a fait partie votre collègue
de députés de Vierzon et bien là encore
nous étions en capacité de nous
retrouver et je suis persuadé que sur la
fin de vie nous serons dépassés nos
clivages alors mes chers collègues cpfss
2023 qualifié par la rapporteur général
de PLFSS de transition car préparer
entre deux mandatures avec un nom
d'homme certes en berne ces bénéfice
n'apportent pas toutes les réponses je
dis bien n'apporte pas toutes les
réponses sur la politique familiale sur
l'hôpital sur le grand âge seul accès
aux soins sur la médecine de ville mais
il consolide je dis bien le consolide un
édifice fragile est très fragilisé miné
par des c'est difficile ébranlés par
l'absence de vision et des mauvaises
décisions pour l'hôpital et la médecine
de ville depuis tant d'années la
désertification médicale ne s'est pas
créée en un jour mais en 30 ans et tout
le monde est responsable
le sous-investissement à l'hôpital je le
dis au collège socialiste a été la règle
pendant 20 ans avant le Ségur en 2021 la
récente valorisation des carrières des
soignants n'est qu'une première étape
monsieur le ministre si on veut redonner
de l'attractivité à ces métiers les
fragilités hospitalières sont la devant
nous la lettre des 4500 praticiens qui
travaillent dans la pédiatrie qui vous a
été adressé la semaine dernière en une
illustration et un plan sentimental et
dans l'attente la cinquième branche mes
chers collègues il dit dans les
ministres de la sécurité sociale la paix
la dépendance tout le monde dit mais
quand est-ce qu'on l'a créé elle a été
créée il y a deux ans certes
insuffisamment financée mais moi ça fait
15 ans qu'on me raconte les mêmes
histoires les uns et les autres
personnes ne l'avait fait auparavant
alors l'avenir des retraites qui nous
rassemblera en début d'année 2023 et
particulièrement de celles et ceux je
vous le dis chers collègues la gravité
qui sont frappés par les difficultés de
la vie je pense au métier pénible je
pense à ceux qui sont victimes de
maladies aux carrières hachées pour les
femmes ne sera assurer que si le plus
grand nombre travail un peu plus dans
son corps dans son parcours
professionnel sinon cette avenir ne sera
pas garanti alors madame la Première
ministre le gouvernement entendu le
Parlement serait donc des questions dans
ce cas de pdfss je voudrais rappeler que
sur les médicaments le référencement
vous avez écouté j'y crois tous ces noms
j'imagine que vous allez tous dire à vos
pharmaciens Vous allez régler le
problème même si vous opposez du dossier
après vous avez entendu naturellement
pour l'industrie pharmaceutique nos
craintes au moment où la France a 85% de
ses médicaments qui sont fabriqués en
dehors de France et du territoire
européen vous avez entendu le souhait
d'innovation thérapeutique vous avez
entendu l'accès direct aux infirmières
qu'on appelle les IPA et des mêmes
expérimentations que on pourra faire
donner aux infirmières justement pour
des certificats de décès vous avez
entendu le cumulon peu retraite ça je
connais bien cette mesure c'est avec 10
ans j'ai essayé de la faire passer ici
jamais passer chacun trouve un sa
responsabilités mais il y a des sujets
madame la Première ministre avec elle
nous n'avons pas assez avancé il faudra
avancer le report du transfert du
cotisations en temps sur carcool
l'URSSAF on a eu un sursaut dynamé nous
serons là pour continuer pour que ce
sursaut c'est insurceau dans la durée la
quatrième année internat monsieur le
ministre pas encore suffisamment préparé
ou en enverra pas les internes être des
tortionnaires dans les territoires sous
dotés il faut reconnaître leur valeur
leurs qualités et leur proposer à notre
avenir et j'aurais aimé que vous
entendiez plus ce Marc Ferrari
lorsqu'ils avaient proposé un abonnement
sur les ajustements de charges sociales
qui auraient permis de faire des
économies notre collègue Meinier qui
n'est pas là sur le convention sélectif
j'aurais aimé également qu'on aille un
peu plus loin sur des propositions que
les démocrates ont pu porter alors chers
collègues si nous voulons apporter
collectivement des réponses fortes à
l'ensemble des branches de la sécurité
sociale notamment sur l'accès aux soins
l'hôpital le grand âge il nous faudra
faire preuve de courage
il nous falloir mettre en place une
nouvelle méthode il nous faudra
collectivement être responsable les
députés démocrates ils sont prêts madame
la Première ministre le courage c'est
d'agir pour notre pays avant notre
partie le courage c'est de rechercher
des improbables solutions mais qui sont
les meilleures réponses parce que elles
sont les fruits des réussites
collectives le courage c'est d'aller à
l'idéal de comprendre comme les agents
Jaurès le courage c'est cette sérénité
active chère à Jean-Paul Mattei à la
recherche du meilleur partage de la
valeur avec la taxe sur les dividendes
le courage
c'est aussi de ne pas rajouter du chaos
chaos et je tiens à remercier les
députés républicains houliote la semaine
dernière qui n'ont pas voté la motion de
censure alors
Sénèque disait
c'est parce qu'on n'ose pas que les
choses sont difficiles alors je vous dis
mes chers collègues
osons ensemble
pour réussir à sortir de cette forme
d'impasse il faudra maintenant la
première ministre une nouvelle méthode
et il vous appartient de faire en sorte
que le gouvernement s'adapte à la
situation inédite d'une assemblée
introuvable et d'éviter le 49,3 le plus
souvent d'abord cette méthode passe par
un lien étroit avec les fameux CNR santé
qui associent les citoyens les experts
les partenaires sociaux les élus pour
que gouvernement et Parlement tiennent
compte des aspirations des citoyens et à
mes yeux par exemple je dis devant le
ministre ce n'est pas aux ARS organisés
les seigneurs santé dans les territoires
et laissons faire les aiguilles locaux
cette méthode passe aussi à mes yeux et
à nos yeux et démocrates pour que le
gouvernement parle en amont très
largement en amont de la préparation des
budgets ou des budgets de la sécurité
sociale démarrer du concertation avec
les groupes parlementaires avec les
acteurs de la sécurité sociale au
quotidien
c'est aussi d'encourager les démarches
transpartisanes dont on a pu voir
qu'elles aboutissaient faciliter
faciliter madame la Première ministre
bien vous l'avez fait a duré plus donc
je vous invite à continuer à lever les
gages sur des propulsions solides et
opérationnelles que nous parlementaires
nous ne pouvons pas porter afin de bâtir
une stratégie pluriannuelle pour la
sécurité sociale cette méthode aussi
passe par des bilans annuels des clauses
de revoyure pour corriger les
trajectoires nous croyez pas chers
collègues que paulaxo aux soins pour la
place de l'hôpital la place de la
médecine de ville de la Suran
administration du système de santé la
place toujours plus importante du
numérique pour améliorer les prises en
charge et l'efficacité des soins ou pour
améliorer encore le bien-être de nos
aînés ce sont des sujets qu'on doit
traiter de façon transversale alors en
conclusion mes chers collèges je vais
vous dire qu'il nous appartient à tous
collectivement des faire preuve de
responsabilité car les finances
publiques exigent des choix maîtrisés on
ne peut plus faire comme avant
un point d'augmentation des taux
d'intérêt c'est 16 milliards chacun le
sait et chacun accomplit les députés
démocrates madame la Première ministre
seront à vos côtés ils sont invoqués
pour relever ces défis
dans un esprit non pas de fronde mais
dans l'esprit de co-construction animée
par une seule et impérieuse exigence de
faire de la France le pays dans lequel
la sécurité sociale redevient le modèle
universel envié par tous et le modèle le
plus juste pour toutes ces raisons parce
que nous avons confiance en l'avenir et
parce que nous refusons le chaos nous ne
voterons pas naturellement s'émotions de
censure je vous remercie je vous
remercie
[Applaudissements]